he's one of our favorite writers uh
covering the nfl and we're figuring you
know what we are nine weeks away from
the season starting right now
joining us back again here on the rich
eisen show is senior nfl rider from
espn bill barnwell how you been bill hey
rich i
that just occurred to me when you said
that that it's nine weeks
it is that way that's staggering i feel
like we're
like a month away until we get to like
august and i'm suddenly in panic mode
because the season's about to start why
why would that panic you build why does
that panic you why would you be
panicking so much work
spreadsheets to update i gotta learn
about all these players who are entering
the league
you know like it's one thing to know
about okay you gotta know the core guys
and everyone knows the core guys but
yeah
to me i gotta make my money on the back
of the roster i got to know who that
third string safety is
for the cincinnati bengals and so i have
to figure out all this stuff at least
for the season start so i always say i'm
going to start
february or march yes and realistically
i always start right around trading
okay so then that's that's an august
thing so i guess the july thing is
you're going to go after the core guys
you wrote a
terrific piece about mvp candidates in
the nfl this year i'll give you the
floor who are your
mvp candidates in the nfl for a season
that starts nine weeks from this very
day bill barnwell
okay so i mean we can start with the
obvious one right patrick mahomes
always going to be the favorite just
because okay you know of course the
numbers are going to be there
and the thing that comes to mind here
the thing that comes up with a bunch of
these guys i'm going to mention here
is that we're moving to a 17 game season
and so suddenly
all these records that might have been
in play in a typical year are
really in play now because we're looking
at that extra game
suddenly we might have the first 2 000
yard receiver
in nfl history in 2021 we have a better
chance that happening
than we had in prior years we might have
patrick mahomes said the passing effort
he might have
a running back like derrick henry set
the rushing record so i think if you're
a record set you know if you're a record
setter
at one of those spots i think that gives
you an edge an opportunity
to be in every candidate maybe in a
typical year that might be harder so
holmes is the favorite but then
you go down the list someone like it
derek henry you know last year 2000
yards didn't really sniff
mvp candidacy but if he could top eric
dickerson's record
and he's a better shot this year than he
had maybe in years past
i think the field opens up a bit or
someone hey let's say someone gets the
25
facts let's say you know uh someone like
a
tj watt or he's a darius smith has that
great season gets that extra game
and not only sets the sacrifice but
blows away the fact record
to me i think that 17th game really
opens up the field
for possible mvp ticks in the nfl this
year okay
and now uh you're who's 1a for you then
if it is not mahomes because you know
the way it works
you know whether it works bill is that
uh after a while
nfl media that votes on this sort of
thing i still don't get a vote on this
sort of thing because i'm an nfl
employee the associated press thinks
that i'm
i'm biased or uh you know that like
roger goodell is going to whisper in my
ear the the one time i am actually in
his presence in a calendar year that he
how to vote um even though he's never
told me a damn thing to say in my career
i'm gonna and i'm now off my soapbox but
you know the way that this thing works
um bill is that people get bored like
all right we've already done that like
we don't have to do it again so give me
a give me a 1a
one c here for you okay one a one b
one c i i will go with let me give you
let me give you three tiers of guys let
me give you a
uh a favorite with the holmes i think
right up there
boring pick but tom brady i mean a guy
who's still playing at a high level
we saw peyton manning a few years ago in
denver his first season you know
very good um some ups and downs but by
the end of the year
was kind of clicking on all cylinders
the playoffs were a bit of a mess unlike
brady but year two
that was one of the best seasons of
peyton's career even at the end of his
career
won an mvp i think tom brady could have
that kind of season in tampa now that
he's more comfortable in the offense
everyone i mean geez everybody's coming
back from last year's team
he gave antonio brown for a full season
he could suddenly be
i i think a guy who even though we know
he's you know a traditional favorite
could get that one last mvp opportunity
this year
second tier i'm going to go with the guy
who we were playing playing us in with
kyler murray i mean a guy was a hot
candidate last year he was
and after that bill's game after that
tell mary i think everybody was talking
about tyler murray as an mvp
candidate but then second half of the
year some injuries cardinals kind of
broke down
um you know his candidacy sort of fell
apart but
we know he has that upside for for me
it's just hey can he put that together
for 17 games can he stay healthy can the
players around him stay healthy
and come to cardinals win the nfc west
because
usually realistically you have to win
the division for
you to win mvp and then i think the long
shot and i don't know what you guys
think about this let me know how you
feel
but jameis winston um a guy who we know
i mean obviously
he has some problems we know that he is
a guy who can turn the ball over
five or six times in the game if you
give him the opportunity
but man i love the weapons around him
with michael thomas and alvin kamara
it's a
dominant offensive line when those guys
are healthy up front and the one thing
that the saints really do not get rid of
this year is they really kept
that core of the offensive line together
um and then
sean payton i mean a guy who is maybe
one of the two or three best minds of
all football
in creating an offense i i have to think
james winston
assuming he starts which again is not a
guarantee uh i
have to assume james winston is going to
look a lot different from the guy we saw
in tampa and if that's the case
and they can win the nfc south i think
he could post some incredible numbers
and that could be a guy who nobody's
thinking about right now but for me
kind of a long shot mvp can't sit there
bill barnwell here on the rich
eisen show if jameis winston wins
the mvp of the nfl
in 2021 if he is that guy that would
mean the saints would have to probably
get a a 12 13 uh
maybe 14 win season in a 17 game
schedule and then i guess brockman
we'd have to take bets on which member
of the nfl media would be first to call
drew brees a system quarterback
you know like i gotta guess you know i
mean
that would be wild bill that would be
totally
uh wild but i understand how prolific he
was
in tampa you know and and all the
interceptions you would assume he would
cut those down
and uh and and earlier on in the uh you
know in the show here before you joined
i had five shrug emoji teams for the nfl
season
where you know you just don't know they
could be play off worthy and go on a
playoff run
or wind up choosing in the top half of
the draft in vegas next year
and i was thinking of putting the saints
as one of those teams
but because you just don't know at that
quarterback spot but i just think that
offensively and defensively they are so
rock solid terrific that
that winston may just be plugged into
that and
and have have the best year of his
career you know i really think so i mean
look at what sean peyton's done over the
past couple years with drew brees hurt
i mean it's been teddy bridgewater
looking
really impressive with that saints team
it's been taysom hill
you know not being drew brees by any
means but they're winning games
with taysom hill at quarterback to me i
think
if you give sean payton an average
quarterback or maybe
even a little worse than average
quarterback and a competent defense
i was going to say he's going to win you
10 games in a 16 game since i don't know
what that means anymore
but he can win you 11 games in a 17 game
season somewhere around there yeah i
mean he's going to be
a winning coach and i think that the
saints do lose some talent this
offseason i think you have to be
realistic about that but
the core of this team outside of the
quarterback situation
is still there and i think that you know
you look at what he's done over the past
couple years he's won games even without
troopers
so you know i i think they don't really
have that floor to be they don't have
that floor of oh we're going to be a top
10 team
picking in this year's drive i could see
them being you know nine and eight eight
and nine maybe having an up and down
season with jameis or casey
quarterback but i can't imagine them
going like five and
a five and twelve or six and eleven they
just don't you know to me i think sean
payton is such a good coach that
he sort of walks you in for seven wins
to even begin with bill barnwell here on
the rich eyes and show senior nfl rider
for
espn nine weeks until the season kicks
off just on this very day
for the nfl 2021 campaign there's one
name that i don't believe we've talked
about yet or we haven't mentioned
in the mvp possibility and that's i
think the hottest candidate that a lot
of people
are are jumping on right now and that's
matthew stafford
of the rams and the situation that he's
been put into
of uh the podcast that my colleague at
the nfl media group peter schrager does
with rams coach sean mcvay for
simmons ringer uh had kyle shanahan on
this week and it was
it was uh quite a conversation that they
had where shanahan
was grinding tape on stafford
and he found out that stafford went to
the rams and he
kind of you know i think he cleaned it
up for the podcast i think it caused him
to work a little blue wherever he was in
the room when he learned about it
because he's so into stafford so
uh what do you think of all that bill i
i'm intrigued and i'll tell you what the
thing i worry about with the rams is not
really matthew stafford's ability i i
really believe that he is an upper
echelon quarterback
with the right pieces around him and we
think that the rams that receiver hey
you can't argue right
cooper cup robert woods tyler higby cam
akers you figure playing a bigger role
in the backfield there's a lot of talent
around matthew stafford but same issue
he had with the lions is that
are people going to be able to protect
him i mean that rams offensive line
not very good the past couple of years
they're relying heavily on andrew
whitworth who to me is
one of the most underrated players in
the nfl over the past 20 years a guy
who's
you know been an upper echelon left
tackle approaching 40.
i mean you know it's not tom brady but
it's pretty close in terms of
you know you're counting on this guy to
be the guy he was years before and maybe
he will be and that's great if he is but
if he's not
there's no plan b for the rams that
offensive line to me
is a problem and you think about the
defense well
brandon staley left he was an excellent
defensive coordinator turned around that
team
they did lose a bunch of pieces in the
secondary jaylen ramsey's still there
but a couple new starters there
in the secondary this is a team that
does not have a lot of cash base a lot
of draft capital to work with they
haven't been able to do very much
in terms of adding talent to this roster
so to me
you know when i think about what an mvp
has to do number one put up great
numbers i think matthew stafford can do
that
number two stay healthy not be staffert
has had some injury issues the past
couple years a tough guy i mean no one's
arguing his toughness but just
at some point you get hit a lot you're
going to get injured and number three
when it comes to winning the division i
kind of think the rams are in the same
spot they were a year ago
granted they did you know put up
impressive season but
uh i can see the offense improving a
little bit faster stafford a quarterback
but the defense
simultaneously taking a step backwards
so to me
um you know i think matthew stafford's a
viable pick i could see him getting
better putting up big numbers but
there are other guys i like a little
more than matthew stafford when it comes
to that sort of
you know those hot candidates like
someone like a baker mayfield i like
more maybe
than matthew stafford bill barnwell here
on the rich eisen show
let's have some fun here bill because we
just talked about
that uh kyle shanahan soundbite on sean
mcvay
peter schrager's pod um i'm talking
about how
uh he was you know frustrated to hear
that the rams got
matthew stafford because he was grinding
tape on stafford when he heard about
stafford going
to the rams begs the question
what were the niners doing grinding tape
on
stafford now that whole situation has
been
resolved because they got trey lance now
so
my question for you that's the setup is
how many teams in the nfl do you think
would cough up their current plans
regardless of who's there
at quarterback to acquire aaron rodgers
how many teams do you think there would
be
like let's walk through it here
literally if you want to go team by team
we can if you want to throw a number out
there that you think
go for it how would you want to answer
that question i'll give you the floor
on that let's go division by division go
forward let's go division by division i
think it's easiest way to do it
afc i don't think the bills are throwing
josh allen out the door
they have to at least have a
conversation but i think they're they're
fully in
on josh everyone else i mean the
quarterbacks are getting tossed out
they're literally you know it's lane
kiffin on the uh
you know on the tarmac at lax in terms
of those guys being left
even even like the jets even bill the
jets who choose a kid
second overall they they choose that
capital they'd cough him up
for aaron rodgers this late in his
career like that's what i mean like
there are a lot of situations
you know where sure you know you take
aaron rodgers over
a raw rookie but you've made plans you
know what i mean like that's
that's what i'm i'm throwing in here
into this mix
you think you would here's the thing i
know i grew up in new york i know a lot
of jets fans
i i think if i pulled a hundred jets
fans to me the first jets fans i know
maybe they're not
uh the most accurate representation but
i feel like they're pretty hardcore jets
fans i feel like 90 of them
would happily say you know what we
haven't had a quarterback like this
for 30 years and aaron rodgers i only
have three or four years left
i'd rather live in that world for three
or four years and and go with aaron
rodgers
then take another shot of zack wilson
after we've seen um you know sam darnold
not take that step forward not be the
guy who we were expecting okay after we
took him in the top three
right um you know aaron rodgers it's not
like he's coming off of a good year i
mean he was the
most valuable player in the national
football league last year to me i think
even if you have a guy a prospect who
you think is a sure thing i think trevor
lawrence
i probably wouldn't do it but i think
anyone below that tier where it's not
okay we think he is
you know a bona fide superstar for the
next 10 years and most of the league
agrees with
us i don't think you have to go for
another what about the browns
do you think they'd they'd they'd swap
out baker for aaron rodgers oh no boy
i mean whenever i suggest the browns
might make an upgraded quarterback
brown's fans get very angry at me
and i understand that baker mayfield is
the guy who's going to ruin that jersey
i mean the guy who
is going to cause brown's fans to take
that jersey with the 36 names of backup
quarterbacks on it or the message
they've had at quarterback
and cause they'll throw it out because
they finally have their guy in baker
mayfield
but this is a guy big baker banfield to
a year ago we were talking about as
a guy might get replaced a guy who was a
mess a guy who you know just capitulated
under the pressure capacity behind a
terrible offensive line
and last year i thought he was very
impressive when things got right
bright scheme right offensive line uh
you know right coach
he was much better but aaron rodgers is
a
a scheme transcendent player to me and i
think a guy who's been able to prove
that
over the course of the last 10 years
baker mayfield obviously much younger
i don't know that he's that scheme
transcendent player i don't know if
baker mayfield's going to be able to
make magic happen when things aren't
perfect for him in that offense so to me
with a roster that i think to is
championship caliber around the
quarterback position
yeah i would make that move every day no
kidding what about uh
well what other some other teams that
might be fun here
to just throw in your direction cause i
i don't think the bengals would
right i mean they love burro um
that they wouldn't make that move i mean
rogers the chargers
no way no chance no way you would have
no chance justin herbert's my unicorn
and don't touch him do you even have a
conversation about it no i don't have a
conversation about it i do not
okay i do not no i do not no herbert i
don't touch i don't touch herbert
um you know um do you touch dak what
about the cowboys let's have some real
fun here
what do you think cowboys and aaron
rodgers we're just trying to get the
uh trying to throw those eyeballs i
don't blame you i mean i
i i love that prescott to me that
prescott is a top seven top eight
quarterback in the nfl um
maybe some other people don't see him at
that level and we're just throwing the
salary cap issues aside here
no no well i mean i think it might be
apples to apples bill
i mean you know um you know with what
what rogers would want
i would imagine so yeah that's fair it's
not too
far why would i make this straight when
i would i
i would rather have rogers i think but
that's the one where i feel like i would
have the longest conversation about it i
think for the cowboys
i think you see rogers upside and dak i
mean i think back is a very high floor
quarterback like i think he's
consistently very good
he's been healthy before of course last
year that freak ankle injury
um i think he's gotten better over the
course of his career but i don't know
that dak has that sort of
you know i'm going to go on the field
and win the game and there's nothing you
can do about it mode
that aaron rodgers does to me i think
the upside for aaron rodgers is the
absolute
undoubted best player in football he's
seen that three times now
over the course of his career that might
not have that upside in him that is
incredible like a super talented
quarterback
but might not be the best quarterback in
football at any time so to me
i think you have to chase that if you
don't think your guy has that and to me
i i would make that trade but i would be
a little petrified
that that press that's a lot better than
people are giving them last one for you
bill barnwell uh who do you think the
mfr was that brady was referring to on
the shop
what do you think um they didn't think
it was me i feel like every quarterback
in the nfl has
i said no no it wasn't me no it's not me
i'm fine i
i think it's the bears i i think it was
miss trubisky
and i may not be the case um but i feel
like the bears of the team where i sat
there last year and i thought
man you have a great defense you have a
very talented receiver and alan robinson
you're maybe playing for your you know
you're gonna be coaching or jamming for
your jobs
go ahead and get tom brady give this a
shot you have the pieces around him
try to make the money work they didn't
do it and to me i think
you know uh mr biscuit no disrespect
that guy who has you know pretty better
than many people have given him credit
for over the past year or two
but a guy who i think everyone saw last
year we thought okay
the bears are really doing this with mr
biscuit nick foles uh
i kind of figured that tom brady would
be a much better option for that so to
me
i'd go back i went titans and tanner
bill really i think kenneth's good no i
know that of course he is
you know and i i i this is not the way i
view tannehill
and maybe not be brady either but you
know
um i i i thought the titans were in on
it i'm you know i'm
trying to sleuth it you know remember
when um vrabel was
uh caught facetiming with edelman and
brady at a syracuse basketball game
before the pandemic and
that i think the titans were in on it
and you know they decided to
stick with tannehill and pay him and
um instead of going with brady i think
that that's the where
i don't know the bears just seem to be
too pat you know what i mean and you
might be right
in the in the long run i just don't know
if brady wanted to go to the
freezing cold of lambo you know you know
what i mean like that's true uh you know
not that tennessee is
balmy in december but i i just don't
i don't know man that's that's the way i
went with that one that's the one let me
say this
uh if there was a uh
lebron-esque special a decision-ass
special
yes where i had to pay 60 and at the end
of it tom brady would reveal who the msr
was
i would say for that you know heartbeat
well we know who the host would be for
that because it'd be the same host
probably
you know by the way i don't know if
you're aware bill perfect
uh uh full circle that that happened 11
years ago today
that this is crazy i know wow thanks for
the chat bill this is fun let's do it
again
appreciate it yeah of course anytime
that's bill barnwell right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here